we are living in very unusual times at
the moment and I wanted to start off by
asking you what have been your
reflections of the the impact that this
pandemic has had on our country I can't
tell you how much I sympathize with the
way everybody has had to enjoy this
unbelievably testing and challenging
time and i-i-i know that so many people
have had the agony of losing you know
their loved ones and the the wildermann
tant anxiety that surrounds everything
and so it is the most awful aspect of a
pandemic like this and and yet we've
seen at the same time people being quite
remarkable and wonderful people in
National Health Service and all the
other key workers who've kept everything
going what do you think it is taught us
about our priorities what what really
matters in life at the moment we have to
put nature back at the center of
everything we do and put it at the
center of our economy which is before
this it's been nature's has been pushed
to the peripheries we've exploited and
dug up and cut down everything as if
there was no tomorrow if it didn't
matter the problem is of course it does
matter as some people been trying to say
for a long time the more we erode the
natural world the more we destroy what's
called biodiversity which is the immense
diversity of life plant life tree like
everything else this marine life the the
more we expose ourselves to this kind of
danger and we've had these other
disasters you know with SARS and Ebola
and goodness knows what else all of
these things are related to the loss of
biodiversity they're called zoonotic
diseases where you end up with with
these diseases being transferred from
animals to humans if you over erode the
natural world so we have to find a way
this time
to put nature back at the center and
that is the way in which if we live in
greater harmony we can find a much more
sensible form of economy it's
fascinating what you say that because I
know that we've spoken in the past about
your concerns that if we don't act now
we are going to see more natural
disasters but you're also saying there
that that we could see more pandemics
like this well this is what so many of
the scientists who understand these
things have been trying to say for a
long time and I'm it's one of the
reasons I tried to get the point across
that we should have been treating the
planet as if it was a patient long ago
so no self-respecting doctor would ever
have let the situation if the planet is
a patient reach this stage before making
an intervention hence you know the
precautionary principle which seems to
me absolutely essential what do you
think are the key priorities the key
themes that we really need to be looking
at in a post co-ed world well first of
all we need to work at how do we create
the kind of recovery that benefits
people helps to get people back to work
again provides real employment around
the world and that can be done of course
by prioritizing certain things that
haven't been prioritized before which is
to recognize the damage being done by
back co2 it seems like very long time
ago but but in January you launch the
sustainable markets council a lot has
changed since then is it now time to rip
up the rulebook or you still feeling
confident that that could be a good
basis for for a global economic model
going forward yes I think you can I mean
I've been as I think I said before I've
been absolutely amazed by well the
transformation that's taken place in the
last year or two in terms of the
financial services sector and the
capital market sector suddenly taking an
interest in sustainable investment
opportunities do you appreciate that
there there is a fear that
that maybe this crisis has made
individuals less receptive to sort of
vision visions of change many people are
still at home they'll be watching this
thinking well I'm still concerned like
my family could get ill I'm concerned
that I don't necessarily know whether
I'm going to have a job going forward
what would you say what would you say
about that
the most important thing obviously is to
make sure the economy can function again
and the people's livelihoods and their
businesses and everything else and
employment is possible that all these
things are going to be have to be
incremental anyway but the point is that
in order to avoid even worse situations
in the future and more disease and we
have to we have to find a way to ensure
that within the next ten years because
otherwise we will lose this battle
against accelerating climate change and
this global warming because if we go on
like this with temperatures rising
inexorably then the whole of life
becomes increasingly impossible how much
will you be pushing for for global
leaders to step up now and and come
together what is a time when actually
many countries could feel disjointed and
be quite inward looking as they try and
fix their own their own economies I
haven't exactly been wasting my time
during this lockdown if you know what I
mean so I've been you know in connection
with all sorts of people have had the
opportunity to do a lot using this
technology I have been communicating
with a lot of people around the world on
these issues it's only catastrophes
which concentrate the mind which means
that for once there might be some real
impetus to tackle all these things which
would be pushed to one side because
everybody said no it's it's irrelevant
you know for instance you could never
get the g20 to concentrate very much on
agriculture forestry or fisheries
because it wasn't considered very sexy
but but these are crucial things this
globally has affected everybody
and it's affected everybody a very
personal ways for example you had the
virus yourself how much did that
motivate you to look at it what can be
done next and where we go forward yes it
makes me even more determined to push
and shove and shout and prod if you see
what I mean and whatever I can do behind
the scenes sometimes but but yes I mean
I I I suppose it did party I mean I was
lucky in my case and and and got away
with it quite likely but I've had it and
I can say Oh understand what other
people have gone through and and I feel
particularly for those for instance who
you know lost their loved ones but we're
unable to to be with them at the time
that's to me the most ghastly thing but
but in order to prevent this happening
to so many more people this is why I'm
so determined to find a way out of this
people are just desperate to see their
families already aren't they it's it's a
it's a challenging time well I mean I
haven't seen my father for a long time
he's he's gonna be 99 next week and so
yes all my grandchildren or anything so
I've been doing but the FaceTime is all
real well how has that been for you
being being disconnected from from your
family is terribly sad then little learn
one's friends but unfortunately you know
at least you can speak to them on
telephones and occasionally do this sort
of thing but it isn't the same is it you
want to you really want to give people a
hug it's been absolutely fascinating
talking to you thank you very much for
taking time and hopefully we will all
meet up again in the ways that that we
usually do so thank you very much sir I
do hope so anyway
thank you random thank you